we are in the window where news will
begin to emerge
maybe as we're on the show regarding
whether or not there were
additional positive test results for
today's batch of off-site pcr tests for
ravens players
i don't know what additional positives
would do the nfl seems hell-bent on
getting this game in
tomorrow 3 40 p.m eastern the game was
bumped another day because players did
not want
to play today with no ability to
practice they practice today
walk through and they get some guys back
they're gonna head to pittsburgh
tomorrow jk dobbins and mark
ingram will join them in pittsburgh they
are back now this game has been delayed
so long that two of the guys who tested
positive
nine days ago are going to be back
tomorrow
so if you kick the can long enough you
get back
the first two players that you presumed
you were going to lose i don't know how
much that's going to help because they
still don't have lamar jackson but
it it's better to have those two guys
and not just
gus edwards and whoever else is hanging
around to run the ball
yeah absolutely mike and you don't want
to be in a situation like the broncos
where
we're in without a quarterback you don't
want to be without one of your leading
running backs or offensive lineman or
whatever it is and they're still going
to be down
they're going to be down a bunch of
players tomorrow night
and i don't give them much of a chance
and i know we're going to talk about
that later in the show
but they do have some guys back and they
will put a legitimate nfl team on the
field so that's a good thing there
one thing mike you pointed this out that
mike tomlin probably wasn't real happy
last week when steelers players went off
about the game being postponed from
thanksgiving night and ruining their
mini buy that they were going to have
i have seen nothing and maybe i
dismissed it but i have seen
nothing from steelers players
complaining about this in the past few
days have you seen anything
i haven't seen anything and i think that
that uh for two reasons first of all
mike tomlin
whether he deliberately allowed them to
use social media to vent or
it just was in a blind spot for him they
slammed the door on that after that
initial wave of complaints we saw last
wednesday and also
there was a period of time where the
steelers
thought maybe they were going to be
in a full-blown outbreak there were a
few days where it got dicey last week
and it could have gone either way and it
ended up resolving in
favor of not having a situation so i
think the
the steelers eventually came to
understand this can happen to
anyone and and you know to get back to
where we were before the season began
everybody understands that there will be
inequities this year there will be
things that we look at and say that's
not
fair well no a lot of things aren't
going to be fair and some things will be
less fair than others like having to
to play on 24 hours notice with no
quarterbacks like the broncos had to do
but the nfl decided in october that
there are 256 boxes to check in the
regular season
and they're going to put a check mark in
as many of them as possible and ideally
in every single one
and that's the most amazing aspect of
this look i
i'm not going to proclaim success
or failure by the nfl big picture
but i think the nfl has found a way to
stay on the bicycle
through some pretty rocky terrain
and we have a full season mike we don't
have a complete season but we do have a
full season they could stop right now
and go to the playoffs and
we'd know who the playoff teams were
we'd feel pretty comfortable with who
those playoff teams are for the most
part i mean it's not going to matter who
wins the nfc east anyway
right so you know we we would have a
full
uh playoff field that that we would feel
good about
i think we know who the best teams in
the nfl are and i think that it would
end up that way if we started the
playoffs next week or the week after and
didn't play any more regular seasons so
they've been very successful up to this
point in getting the games in
and yes they it hasn't always been uh
competitively favorable to some teams
we knew that going into the season that
was probably going to happen
and it has unfortunately for the broncos
and some other teams that have had to go
through this
uh with limited personnel short
practices
no notice whatever the case may be every
team pretty much
has gone through this this season
we've made the comparison to baseball
several times this year the bottom of
the fifth
scenario the game becomes official the
season now
you could say is official because
everyone's played at least 11 games and
in 1982
everyone played exactly nine games and
they crowned a champion with 16 playoff
teams
the difference though is in 1982 they
knew when the season was going to end
now and there were fewer teams also
there were four fewer teams correct me
if i'm wrong but at least four fewer
teams there were 28 teams in 1982
16 of the 28 teams made it to the
playoffs i i have kicked around this
idea and i'm just going to spitball
it we got some time here so i'm just
going to throw it out there and see what
you think of it shireen
if there would be some crazy development
now where all of a sudden everything is
haywire and the nfl says we just can't
proceed
the game is over the season is done
we're going to progress to a post-season
at some point in early january we're
shutting it all down
i think what they should do if they get
to a point where these teams that are
trying to make a late kick
can't get that fair opportunity to make
their late kick whether it's the 49ers
whether it's the vikings whether it's
any team out there that's
in the hunt when you look at the playoff
picture how about
24 teams in the postseason
but it would start with the last
eight would it be the last eight
whittling it down
i had an idea and i i can't get my arms
around it but i
i want to get to 16 eventually but the
last
maybe it would be 20 teams that get in
the last four
would play each other like 12 would get
a buy and
eight would whittle the four maybe
that's it you put 20 teams in there it
is not 24.
20 teams get in and the last eight
become the last four seeds of one
through sixteen what do you think of
that
i i actually like that and i think
everyone would like that i think teams
in the nfl would like that i think fans
would like that they would eat that up
because it'd be obviously single
elimination
get more teams in the playoffs you never
know what can happen once you get there
you know a team like the 49ers say they
get jimmy garoppolo back and some of the
players they were talking about today
that they may be getting back would you
want to play them in the postseason
i certainly wouldn't even if they're
that last seed to get into the
postseason so you never know what would
happen with some of those lower seated
teams but i think would be fantastic and
i think
fans would love that too and the teams
at the bottom certainly would love that
like you said a team like the vikings
who's fighting to get in
maybe they go get in the playoffs and
get hot with alvin cook
and i misspoke earlier the ravens are
heading to pittsburgh
tonight planes i'm told leave at seven
o'clock
eastern and as of now 509 pm eastern
no news of any positive pcr results from
the testing that was done earlier today
so good news for the ravens
good news i would still be a little
nervous about getting on the plane but
double mask it eye goggles keep your
distance
and hold your breath as long as you can
on the short trip from baltimore to
pittsburgh by plane
and we're going to talk later about some
of the x's and o's and how this game's
actually going to go but there will be a
foot
football game tomorrow uh and and you
know didn't the nfl learn earlier this
year
not to put a game on while we're on what
the hell is that
so we're going to be multi we're going
to be multitasking maybe some unofficial
supplementary play-by-play
of the game itself while we are on the
air tomorrow at 5 p.m eastern
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports